okay uh thanks for the very kind
introduction dick
okay so let's get started so I guess
most of you work in one way or the other
on on algorithms so what you're usually
trying to do is that you you have your
favorite problem that you're working on
and then you would love to come up with
an algorithm where you can you can show
it's an efficient it's an efficient
polynomial algorithm but life is not
always that nice and and that easy
you may have figured out so not every
problem actually has an efficient
algorithm this is one of the classical
problems that probably is hard and
remind you this is the Hamiltonian
circuit problem the input is some some
undirected graph and you only have to
answer a question just this graph
contain a cycle that visits every node
precisely once something like this so
this is an np-complete problem for
questions I refer to tick what what the
definition of NP completeness is what
this actually means is that Hamiltonian
circuit belongs to a large class of at
least thousands of known problems that
are all kind of have the same hardness
in the sense that you can reduce every
of the problem to every other one and it
has been conjectured that there is no
polynomial time algorithm for this big
class of problems this is the P versus
NP problem this has been around well and
it since the seventies it's on the list
of seven the lynnium problems and
there's a there's in a world of
$1,000,000 if you want to solve the
problem that's probably the hardest way
to earn 1 million dollars these days
okay so if I tell you sure that there is
no no efficient algorithm I always find
this as a bit of a vague statement but
there's actually it's a very precise way
of stating this it's nice to to to
phrase the problem as a as a as a
circuit problem
so you can imagine you can you can
freeze whatever np-complete problem we
have you can define a boolean function
which may look like this this is imagine
this is a boolean function representing
your Hamiltonian circuit problem the
function has some inputs let's say n
many inputs these are bits and it has
some output which is also going to be
some bit and if you wonder how you put
your camel tone Ian circuit problem in
this then you could say that you let's
say you order the edges in your in a
complete graph you denote them by e1 to
en and then the if' input bit is just
whether the ifetch is in the in your
input graph or not so this way you can
you can represent every graph on about
route and many vertices you can
represent that with the 0 1 string of
inputs and then this function should
tell you whether that represented graph
does contain a Hamiltonian circuit or
not and so everything you have to do is
that this boolean function needs to have
a large number of gates and if you you
can see some made-up example of gates
here for example this is this is a NAND
gate it gets 2 bits as input and it has
maybe 1 bit as an output and there's a
there's an or gate and they're also not
gates and the questions like how many of
these gates do you need to to represent
their function and the P versus NP
question it's basically equivalent to
showing that whatever np-complete
problem you have the number of gates you
need a super polynomial basically
equivalent model or some small
technicality okay so this this is clear
ok so this is a nice and concrete
question now we can wonder actually what
do we know about like the number of
gates you need for certain explicit
np-hard functions and so thirty years
ago the state of the art was a lower
bound of three n for some explicit
actually very simple function something
explicit and now thanks to 30 year of
extensive research and millions and
millions of dollars of very well
invested taxpayer money we can improve
the second second digit behind the comma
you could be mean and like interpolate
that at this speed of progress it takes
around 3,000 years until we reach a four
and bound progress is somewhat slow on
this side actually as a little anecdote
there's a nice web page of Garrett
working er where he lists all the the
attempts of people trying to prove
whether P equals NP or not the last time
I checked he had a hundred on sixteen
archive submissions of some people
proving well submitting like some bran
claims probably bran claims about a
solution so and I think this is pretty
unique and like the whole area of
mathematics I'm not aware of any Pro
problem where people submit that number
of incorrect submissions okay I want to
talk a little bit about one of the one
of the early claims which is actually by
a Canadian mathematician smart that's
from the 80s he claimed that he would
equal to NP and the way that he claimed
he had solve the problem was by by
modeling the Hamiltonian circuit problem
that I just defined as a linear program
nowadays we would be very quick to to
just dismiss these kind of attempts I
dict out one of the the old Optima
newsletters this is the one from from 86
and if you read this then you see that
more if correct it would be a
revolutionary claim it is only
professional to be suspicious but at
this time we know of no one who is
either verified the approach or proved
it fatally flawed so in other words that
time it wasn't actually
and what's actually plausible that it
could have been true
let's phrase it that way okay when you
explained a little bit more about this
so first of all what is that linear
program linear programming that I that I
talked about so linear program it's it's
kind of a mathematical optimization
problem with simple form you have some
inequality some linear inequalities your
solution is some continuous vector in R
to the N and what you're trying to do is
you're trying to let's say maximize some
linear function this is best explained
you know another picture so if you are
if you draw the the the half spaces
belonging to this linear system you get
some some inequalities and the
intersection like the set of solutions
to this system it's going to be of this
form
it's whatever what is called a polytope
and if you now try to optimize a linear
function then you can see that well if
there are vertices that you're gonna be
optimal at one of the vertices of the
polytope so linear programs can be
solved efficiently both in theory and
then any practice and in particular the
the folks of in operations research they
they love their linear programs because
whenever you can model your favorite
problem as an e a program then you're
kind of done you know that they are very
good algorithms to solve your problem
and so it's not completely back in the
days it was not completely insane to
hope that linear programs as they are
quite powerful that they could solve
your your np-hard problem okay there's
one detail that actually linear
programming it's about it's a continuous
optimization problem and Hamiltonian
circuit it is actually it's a discrete
question it's the set of solutions it's
it's discrete it's a finite set of
solutions it's not a contradiction if
you think about it
the way you how he can model in
principle model every optimization and
every discrete optimization problem as
an inner program is the following you
can look at yourself the set of your
solutions let's say the characteristic
vectors of your Hamiltonian circuits in
let's say in the complete graph they are
in some higher dimensional space this is
your 1 vectors living in some high
dimensional space and you can you know
look at them and you can look at the
convex hull of them and if you had some
basic course on linear programming then
you know that the convex hull of a
finite number of points it's actually
also pollito ticular you can also
represent the same space the same set of
solutions as just the intersection of a
finite number of half spaces so you can
also write it in in this inequality form
and now if you have a concrete graph and
you want to know whether your concrete
graph does contain a Hamiltonian circuit
you can do the following you can take
the characteristic vector of that graph
so it's a 0 1 vector that has ones
wherever you have an edge and you can
just optimize it over that space of
solutions and you'll get some optimum
then you only need to see whether that
optimum point well it will correspond to
to a Hamiltonian circuit and then you
just need to check whether that
Hamiltonian circuit is actually in your
graph and if that's the case then the
answer to your question was yes this
graph does have a Hamiltonian circuit
otherwise it doesn't ok so this is a
fairly standard approach to model your
problem you discrete problem as a let's
say linear program or it's a Polito so
this is somewhat what what's word had in
mind if you think about it what is
actually the important quantity here
then well you can solve the system
efficiently with a linear programming
solver well as long as the
of inequalities a small so that's kind
of the number that you care about okay
so in a usually one might think that the
only thing you have to do is you have to
count how many how many facets does this
object this Polito have and that would
give you the number of inequalities but
actually linear programming is a little
bit more powerful and that's not exactly
the number that you should look at why
not for example let's look at this poly
tope which imagine it lives in two
dimensions it lives in the plane that's
a little bit tilted and if you count
then this this object has eight many
facets so you would naively need eight
many inequalities if you wanted to
represent that poly tope okay but now
let's look at this three-dimensional
polytope and so this three-dimensional
polytope queue up here it has six facets
so if you think about this geometrically
you could actually represent this with
six many inequalities moreover if you
imagine you're projecting down this this
this poly tube and if I did draw things
correctly you would actually project
down at the shadow would be P so what
this actually means is that there is
some lower dimensional poly tube with
many eight many facets but it is the
projection of a higher dimensional
higher three-dimensional polytope that
has that has fewer facets it has fewer
inequalities from the mathematical
programming perspective what you're
doing is that you have a you have a
problem that needs a lot of inequalities
in the original space but now you're
you're you're adding some extra
variables to your linear program and
that reduces
the number of inequalities that you need
possibly dramatic so there are actually
examples where the original polytope has
exponentially many needs exponentially
many inequalities in the original space
but after adding some some extra
variables it needs only polynomially
many many inequalities so there is some
mechanism that actually allows linear
programs to be quite powerful in many
settings and in particular it's not very
clear whether you know this power is
enough for solving a Hamiltonian circuit
okay this is maybe a little bit abstract
I want to go back to him on tuning
circuit and explain a little bit how
maybe one could cook up some some linear
program okay this is a linear program
that tries to model Hamiltonian circuit
this is actually from the literature
this is the so called subtour
elimination of p ok so let me let me try
to explain this so there's some ok so
what we're actually trying to do is that
we trying in some graph we're trying to
find a Hamiltonian circuit and let's
imagine we're directing the edges so
we're trying to find something like this
and and there are some more edges around
okay but I'm not drawing okay so if you
model this as a linear program then you
may want to have some variables XE that
tell you whether you want to use that
edge in your Hamiltonian circuit or not
ok ok so what is actually u Hamiltonian
circuit if you look at it like for every
node you have one incoming edge and you
have one outgoing edge if you gave
things directions ok so maybe you want
to add that as a constraint so for every
node if you sum over the outgoing edges
that's 1 and you sum over the incoming
edges that's 1 ok so far so good now you
you're wondering is this actually is
this enough well not really maybe what
you have is something like this and you
know this is a
beautiful subgraph where you know
outgoing degrees 1 incoming degrees 1
but it doesn't actually really look like
a Hamiltonian cycle in the sense that
this thing is not connected so you kind
of you need to add some something that
gives you connectivity several ways how
you can do that this is the one that you
know I'm choosing here I say that well
for every for every you and every V
there should be a way to to go from u to
V using the edges that you just bought
and that's not satisfied here but you
could satisfied with the following
constraints there are some these are
some extra variables so it means that
actually this is already we already use
extra variables here that we actually
would need and now this says that well
if you stare at every pair UV there is
well this is called it's a flow of
strength one going from you to B so this
actually ensures that there's a way to
go from from you to B so this gives you
some kind of connectivity ok ok so
question would be now if you solve this
linear program which you can do
efficiently is this gonna give you an
answer to your Hamiltonian circuit
problem no it does not because this is
an example this is a graph that people
working in the field have seen like a
billion times you can put if you put XE
weights like this a quarter on these
thin edges and the hop on the thick
edges then this thing will satisfy these
constraints
you also have connectivity but there is
no Hamiltonian circuit contained in in
these edges so it's kind of the a linear
program would tell your fault solution
the near program is feasible even though
there is no Hamiltonian circuit ok so is
this the LP that swart
claimed was doing the job no
basically what smart was doing is that
he had a more complicated linear program
with you know more variables more
inequalities but and you basically it
had the same issue that there was some
fractional solution that actually would
not correspond to a Hamiltonian circuit
if you if you want like a geometric
picture of the whole story then you can
imagine that this is the solution space
somewhere in some high dimensional space
of the subtour elimination LP and this
might be the actual convex hull of the
Hamiltonian circuits with like you know
every vertex corresponding to a zero one
vector of a of a Hamiltonian circuit and
the problem is like this solution here
that I showed you in that space it would
be like one of these points here so
there would be points there are feasible
for the LP but they are actually not in
the convex hull of the Hamiltonian
circuits okay okay so far so good but
the issue is did swert actually have any
chance of being correct so in the sense
if now someone publishes a paper saying
that our I can solve Hamiltonian circuit
with a linear program of polynomial size
might that person actually be true you
need to spend hours and hours finding a
back in the paper to be precise you need
to have your graduate student spending
hours and hours of the weekend finding
the back and so I want to actually give
you the answer to this question okay he
cloud think the graduate students are
not listening right okay actually good
okay so there was a partial answer
actually very quickly after smarts
result this is a it's a beautiful paper
of Jana caucus and I believe yeah caucus
actually looked at smarts paper and what
he observed whoa
that they suggested in your program
it was symmetric in a certain sense and
if you can imagine that if you have a
graph and you're looking for a
Hamiltonian circuit you probably won't
write down a linear program that kind of
treats vertices no differently it's kind
of probably if you rename the name if
you rename the vertices you could also
rename the variables in a certain way
that actually your linear program hasn't
changed and Jana Crockett could actually
prove that any such linear program that
satisfies the symmetry assumption any
such in a program for the Hamiltonian
circuit problem must have exponential
size and now it sounds like we're almost
done but there's actually no
mathematical reason why for whatever
problem symmetrically in the program
should be the best in fact there are
some examples where one can prove that
this is not the case so it's a partial
answer it's a strong indication that you
know what you'll be able to remove this
word of the metric this assumption but
it took a surprising a quarter of a
century until some people including some
of the participants of the program
current program proved that there's
actually no linear program whatsoever
for Hamiltonian circuit so in particular
this is the paper by a fury Nima's our
putative oriental wolf and the low point
they have it's exponential or sub
explanation however you want to call
that that number so that's great it
means you can just read the abstract off
the paper and then reject it so that's
it so it's a wonderful way to preserve
you know capacities if you're a reviewer
okay and I want to talk a little bit
about this result just how in principle
could you prove such a lower bound
because this is this is completely
unconditional lower bound and you should
compare this with the pretty much
failure of lower bound for general
circuits
and if things are getting too technical
please stop me slow me down I think we
have a little bit of so this okay this
result does not rule out that you have a
separation that you have a pony number
time separation Oracle and I'm pretty
sure that if you rule out as a
polynomial time separation Oracle then
you also have prove that p is not NP so
in some sense this is like the only
thing that you can do before you end up
on K hard-working as webpage one way or
the other maybe maybe you end up you
know like the only good paper but anyway
okay so let me explain a little bit okay
so to be precise the lower bound does
not directly apply to that convex hull
of the Hamiltonian circuit it applies to
a different poly tope that's called the
correlation pony tow but you can
transfer the lower bound by observing
that the correlation bullet obits
actually it linearly maps to what's
called the face of the Hamiltonian
circuit polytope and then if there is no
small inner program for this thing there
is no small in your problem for this
thing because otherwise you can just you
know set some of the the constraints as
inequalities and and you also have a
small in your program for this thing so
okay this was an unconvincing and we'll
come to that yeah we'll come to that on
one of the next slides so okay so but
just don't be don't be confused if I
show you a lower bound for something
that's not the thermal toning circuit
problem poly tope but it's there's a
pretty simple reductions like a kind of
like one of the simple and hardness
reductions here
anyway okay good
so one of the very basic concepts in
this whole theory of like how small my
linear program has to be it's the
concept of slack matrix so let me try to
explain you that so let's take let's say
Kappa little P and let's look what the
slack matrix should be it's a it's a
huge matrix which for every of the
facets of your poly tope like put like
this is the facet of your Polito for
every facet you have a row and for every
vertex you have a column and the entry
that you have it gives the slack that
the vertex has with respect to that
facet okay so it's it's some
non-negative number that basically is
proportional to the distance of the
vertex 2 2 2 to that hyperplane this is
it's a giant matrix for most polytopes
you have exponentially many rows and
they exponentially many columns ok so
the next concept that you need is what's
called the non-negative rank so like
probably everybody of you knows what's
the rank of a matrix the rank of the
matrix asked to factor a matrix as as u
times V and these are like smaller
matrices we are trying to minimize the
number of of columns of the left vector
and the number of rows of the right
factor that's the rank and they're like
the number of you know columns here that
you need that's the rank the minimum
number is your rank okay and
non-negative rank it's it's an extension
where you require that both of your
factors U and V both of the matrices
that you're using to factor as they only
have non-negative entries and that's the
non-negative rank so in particular the
non-negative rank is a quantity that's
always at least as large as the usual
rank but it may be a lot higher okay and
good so why am I explain
meaning this this concept of slack
matrix non-negative rank we actually I
want to talk about you know the size of
linear programs and and here is the the
very useful theorem of Jana car keys
back from the end of the 80s which is
the following that you can take any
polytope you can look at the slack
matrix s and the smallest number of
inequalities that you need for something
higher dimensional that projects down on
P so this is called the extension
complexity so this quantity that we
actually want to know about it equals
the non-negative rank of the slack
matrix okay and this guy yes this is far
betray yeah it's a good question thanks
ok so why this is good because we're
trying to to bounce something something
geometric like the number of
inequalities that some object needs that
projects down on on your target polytope
and we can do something that looks more
concrete we can just look at that slack
matrix of your poly tope and we can just
pound the the non-negative rank it's not
that we would know yet how to do that
but it sounds like this is something
it's something nicely algebraic maybe
when can do something okay in fact
that's the way how it goes I don't want
to go too much into the proof here the
first time you see the claim it's not so
clear why they should be true if you
stare at a picture you might get an idea
why okay so give me one minute
okay so this is this is our target poly
2p and if you look at one of the one of
the facets and one of the vertices then
you know this vertex has some distance
some slack with respect to this
constraint and now if you look at
something higher dimensional that
projects down on P then actually
this constraint it must be a
non-negative combination a non-negative
linear combination of normal vectors up
here and if you look at this vertex and
you look up here there's going to be
some point in Q that you know project it
down here and this guy here he also has
some distances with respect to those
those constraints up here and now if you
take the same non-negative combination
of the distances that this guy has with
respect to inequalities here then you're
actually getting precisely this distance
to this guy due to that inequality then
it's a little vague but it's like a
one-line calculation if you write things
down and you like stare at it long
enough then you actually see that this
is going to be true okay okay so let's
take this okay good okay so there's
gonna be one principal problem that okay
if we want to show lower bounds for the
size of linear programs we have to show
a lower bound for the non negative rank
of some huge matrix but how do we do
that and there is a very nice community
real way of lower bounding that non
negative rank and that's by looking at
what's called the rectangle covering
number and trying to explain you how
that works okay so let's look at a non
negative matrix as and let's look at
some non negative factorization so in
particular if you see look at this
matrix then this matrix its you can
factor it as u times V and these are
also non-negative matrices kind of lower
bound like the number of columns and the
number of rows here and it actually
suffices to only look at the support of
the matrices so you forget all the
numbers you just look at other number 0
or are they strictly positive and if you
now look at the first column of U and
the first row of V then there are going
to be some positive entries and the
product of a positive entry and a
positive entry plus some other
non-negative numbers is going to be
something strictly positive so wherever
you have something positive here you
will have something positive here so in
particular if you look at this the
support of this column and the support
of this row then they're Cartesian
product is going to be it gonna be
what's called a combinatorial rectangle
in the support of s you can play the
same game with all the other rows and in
particular you can see that every of the
positive entries in Aires is going to be
covered at least once but none of the 0
entries is going to be covered
so that gives us a beautiful lower bound
in the sense that the non-negative ring
of this matrix is going to be at least
the number of these combinatorial
rectangles that you need to cover the
support where none of your rectangles is
allowed to contain one of the zero
entries it's a nice community Oriole
lower bound that may be good or may be
bad you don't know okay the nice thing
is this is going to work for our case of
that correlation polytope that I still
haven't yet defined any question so I
mean you can take combinations of any
vector in you with any vector fields so
I would expect to get something like
r-squared community rectangles in s not
just R so you're thinking about like
this product with these guys well you're
never you there's no product it's like
if you if you like this number here it's
this product Plus this product but
okay good uh finally ladies and
gentlemen the correlation polytope it's
defined mathematically in a very compact
way you just take every zero one vector
and then you take the outer product with
itself and you take the convex on so for
example in in for N equals two you just
look at the convex all of ya think of
this as being like n square dimensional
vectors so these are like n square
dimensionals your one vector as well
eclis n by n matrices so these are the N
by n matrices of Rank 1 or 0 okay by the
way it's an np-hard
put it up in the sense that it's kind of
allows you to optimize quadratic
functions so it's not too hard to show
that no optimizing linear functions that
we hired over this bullet okay
but we won't show that the extension
complexity of this thing is exponential
okay so now what you should do is you
should first of all you should know what
is the slack matrix so that's a little
bit of an issue okay so the vertices of
the correlation polytope they are of a
very easy form like very explicit form
that's nice we actually don't know all
the inequalities describing the polytope
there are reasons why we will never know
all the inequalities explicitly but
there is a nice family of inequalities
that we can explicitly write down and it
goes as follows you take any zero one
vector a and you do the following you
take twice the diagonal matrix you get
out of a minus a a transpose and that
multiplied with any point in the
collation polytope is going to be at
most one okay you can take my word for
it you can sit down for a couple of
minutes and do the math to the
calculation and it actually so
to see that what is the distance what is
the slack that every vertex has with
respect to P and then by convexity
reasons you know you will also know that
every point inside of the correlation
Polito will have a non negative slack
with that inequality something very
beautiful happens that if you look at a
vertex of the form be B transpose then
it's slack with respect to this
inequality it's precisely 1 minus the
number of ones that a and B have in
common
squared so it's it's a very nice
explicit formula that you can get it's
also nice that something squared is
always non-negative so that's you know
this seems right in particular the the
claim that one can prove is that the
corresponding slack matrix of this thing
it will have a high non-negative rank
okay so this is this is the slack matrix
that I mentioned we we can get a row for
every zero one vector a we can get a
column for every zero one vector B and
then the entry that we're gonna see here
it's the formula that we just figured
out it's 1 minus a intersect B square
okay so what remains to prove to be
proven is that this thing has a high
non-negative Frank okay and this is just
just a one slide outline and then the
hardest part is done okay
in particular there there are two types
of entries that are particularly
interesting if you if you look at this
if a and B are disjoint if these are 0 1
vectors and they don't have a common one
then this is 0 so you have 1 minus 0
squared so you'll see a 1 in the matrix
and if you have if a and B share
precisely is single entry that is 1 then
you will see a 0 here and zeros are
particularly important for this
rectangle covering
about okay so what remains to be proven
is that if you're trying to cover the
one entries the the positive entries
here with combinatorial rectangles that
are not allowed to include zero entries
then you need exponentially many of them
okay so you can do a little bit of
counting like how many of these entries
do you see okay so how many 0 1 vectors
in n dimensions can you get where they
are disjoint you never have a one at the
same position they are precisely three
to the end because for every position I
there are three choices like both 0 1 1
here or 1 one or the other okay
and so the only non-trivial thing that
you need to prove and that I will have
to skip here is that you need to show
that whenever you have a combinatorial
rectangle then it's it's never going to
contain more than 2 to the N more of
those 1 entries here assuming that the
rectangle doesn't contain any of the
zero entries you okay that's it's a one
page combinatorial proof very elegant
but Allah I have this give me 2 to the N
probably for correlation yes
okay I'm sorry sorry sorry okay the Lord
this will about probably not right
there's a 2 to the N upper bound I think
that that's not hard to get 3 to the N I
don't think that this is not ok so where
is this lower bound coming from well you
have three to the N many you know number
like entries you have to cover every
rectangle covers only that many so the
ratio of that that's the lower bound on
how many rectangles you need and that is
a lower bound on how
inequality is any higher dimensional
object needs that project star on the
creation pollito I don't know I would
disagree so suppose you could show that
it requires explanation of constraints
and ok so for example let's look at that
correlation polytope so if you rule out
that there is no polynomial time you
show that there is no polynomial time
separation that also shows that there is
no polynomial time optimization problem
because you have an equivalence between
polynomial time optimization and
polynomial time separation so you're
showing that I cannot not in polynomial
time optimize over the correlation
Polito and that's an NP NP complete
problem so I think it would actually
show that P is not empty
okay so ah good so this is this is a
little bit uh yeah that was kind of the
state of the art after the paper by a
fury Nia at all actually it's a little
bit of thinking here
so there is an np-complete problem where
we have proven that there's no
polynomial sizing a program representing
the corresponding poly tope on the other
hand actually linear programming it
belongs to some of the hardest problems
in PE there's a way how you can make
this form or you can show that you can
take any problem in P and there is a
there's a reduction that only needs lock
space and you can transform that into a
linear program and then the solution to
the linear program it's going to tell
you the answer to your problem in P so
can you put both things together and
this was some time that you know people
were actually wondering like it's this
is the good there's gonna be a path to
proving the feast on unfortunately not
so this is not going to work and try to
explain you why not in particular there
is going to be an easy problem like
computationally easy problem where we
can also show that there is no small LP
for it and this is going to be the
matching problem okay so first of all
what is the perfect matching and perfect
matching in the internet prophets it's a
pairing between vertices where every
vertex are paired precisely once and now
you can again look at at the
corresponding poly tope which is gonna
live in in some high dimension space
dimension corresponding to the number of
edges in the graph and every of the
vertices it's going to correspond to the
characteristic vector of one of the
matchings one of the perfect matching
so it's gonna be like again some zr1
Victor same story as for a Hamiltonian
circuit differently here for this
polytope
it's a computationally easy polytope in
the sense that if you give me any
objective function you can actually
optimize in that direction in polynomial
time and find the optimum vertex and
this corresponds to putting weights on
the edges of your complete graph and
finding the maximum weight perfect
matching in that graph there's a point
over time algorithm already known since
the sixties due to admins on the other
hand one can actually prove that if you
if you try to represent this polytope as
the projection of some higher
dimensional object that object will
still require exponentially many
inequalities so there is no way to solve
the perfect matching problem by a single
linear program strangely you can solve
it with you know with the polynomial
number of different linear programs but
not with one so this means that if you
go back I don't think you'll you'll have
a chance to use much of the technology
that has been developed improving lower
bounds for linear programs to also show
lower bounds for circuits so that may
not work so there are some extensions
more recently for semi definite programs
and if I have two minutes all people but
you see me different program it's it's
of the form that you have a given matrix
that you require to be positive semi
definite and symmetric and there are
some linear inequalities it's not always
easy to like imagine how this object
looks like if you write down some
example then you see that actually it's
a convex program so the set of solutions
capital ax is going to be it's going to
be convex
it's in general not polyhedral so that
convex said it can have an infinite
number of you know you may need an even
number of inequalities so to speak
they're kind of up to form that well I
mean this is equivalent to saying that
you know this thing is positive
semi-definite is like saying that x
times some back the other product of a
vector with itself should be
non-negative so you have an infinite
number of constraints of very particular
type and semi definite programs they are
more powerful than linear programs in
the sense that there is an there are
some beautiful results that you can use
an SDP to get a good approximation for
Mac's card within 13% of the optimum but
you can't get better than two with the
polynomials linear program so by now we
actually have a very clear separation
between what the semi-different program
can do versus what the linear program
can do and a little bit the end of the
story is that by now there are also
lower bounds for the size of semi
definite programs also for that same
correlation polytope and they're also
somewhat of a exponential size by this
is then the last one is by lia
Ragavendra and Steuer from two years
back okay I'm a little bit at the end of
my talk open questions there is the
obvious one is that there was the
problem that we actually want to solve
is show unconditional lower bounds for
algorithms or equivalently for you know
circuits we still don't know how to do
that but if we can do that if we can't
do that can you maybe at least show
lower bounds on classes of algorithms
that are meaningful it's not so clear
what class is that should be maybe some
general type of dynamic programming
something algebraic can you show me
lower bounds on classes of algorithms
that cover a good chunk of polynomials
or other problems
preferably including matchings and that
would be a nice thing but I'll close the
end thank you take some questions
so the little pump urania
sub-exponential it's this improved now
or is it still the best that we know it
I think there's a I think it to to the
unbound you get it from the matching
result that I had so you get some
slightly improved bound for my imaging
gone yes yes and I think - yeah probably
that's the best possible yeah
found you have this rectangle cover as a
lower ground
some geometric property the
oh nothing out of the top of my head
questions
it's not a comment that matching
actually penned this table is one linear
program with ellipsoid my participation
and in fact I'm not mistaken five
billion how I think it was in the 80s
showed for the first time that they'd be
matching problem solving polynomial time
by ellipsoid separation well the point
is like for separation you're allowing
an arbitrary polynomial time algorithm
and you know these approaches don't rule
out that yeah
superb extra variable control with
coefficients ready to meet greatest
comebacks over
so we're customers in between of the
cases where found indecisive
coefficients forces you to have the
expansion oh well this is not captured
in the lower bounds the lobe on say I
don't care about that
and I don't have a nice I don't have a
nice example where you would have a
separation where there is a small LP
with ugly numbers but there is none with
like putting in Minden numbers
[Applause]